what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts where every
morning I say I'm gonna quit coffee and
I don't and then I give you my thoughts
while I drink coffee
um so today I'm on the road so I'm
actually gonna be doing a reaction video
playback and I'm a bit nervous because
they had quite a wild thumbnail but it's
men should never date fat woman I don't
believe I said that
I don't believe I said that playback
time I won't knock you for it you're a
bigger cannot find love you can however
as a result of the fact that you're
bigger your pool of men is become
smaller unfortunately I'm really not
denying that but where I have an issue
is pushing any narrative that makes it
seem like they're not deserving of the
man that they were but they aren't but
they aren't you are just do the work no
no I'm saying you're not deserving if
you're obese you don't deserve a guy
that makes six figures if you're obese I
don't think anyone
okay
keyword deserves we don't deserve any
Fair cabin alone what the [ __ ] that's I
don't like that at all nah nah she now I
don't like that at all I was on I was on
her page for a little while but I didn't
like that at all now Tick Tock got upset
at her for saying this now well no no I
think she misheated yeah she misspoke
but she's was basically saying is if
you're obese you're probably gonna have
less options you say that yeah yeah but
like six figures is not like you could
be overweight I don't know it's like
she's saying what she's saying as if
like it's a it's a qualifying like yeah
like it's going to be harder for you to
find men like that just to be fair but
like they say you don't deserve it
though who knows how do you know who
deserves it I'm gonna say You're Gonna
Be You skinny as hell you can be in
shape that still doesn't mean that you
deserve somebody yeah that's what I was
saying nobody deserves anyway it was
crazy do you know what's crazy I could
say Instagram models you don't deserve a
man that makes six figures the Instagram
models
they would they wouldn't go crazy they
wouldn't go mad
but fat chicks somehow
think they're better than everyone else
because they're the only ones that get
mad
dessert that that's the word deserve
deserve I don't think I deserve a man
that makes six figures and you know what
that shouldn't be controversial that's
the top 10 of earners
that's like a broke fat dude he could
just be broke you know he doesn't even
have to be fat let's say a broke dude
saying you know what I don't deserve a
Victoria's Secret model that's like them
saying I don't deserve Beyonce
they'd be like yeah you know what
probably not probably not yeah it was
crazy if I dated someone who was obese
I've done it before she was fat but but
to say that somebody deserves it's
fantastic wear her ring though wear her
ring though okay whatever somebody is
crazy because like what do you like how
do you how do you what is your litmus
test off of deserving somebody also does
that mean that does that mean that if
I'm dating somebody and she's fit but
then like let's say she gets pregnant or
whatever maybe she just like has grown
some bad habits she gets overweight she
doesn't deserve my love oh she she's on
this planet too show me someone that
looks good at 300 pounds y'all are just
proving my point
crazy no I'm not gonna lie I met someone
that looked at 300. so that but that's
but that's what that she didn't want to
say like yo show me somebody who look
good at 300. but yeah but they they show
up they should they showed a compilation
of women that were like 300 pounds and
she was like y'all prove my point like
none of them were good if you had a
point to prove you would prove it with
like facts and evidence not just your
your oh my God it was crazy
I could take dating app data I could go
on the street and say who would you
rather Smash and do a 300 pound girl and
a 120 girl
and and the fat chicks would still not
believe me like this shouldn't be
controversial
and then they're like oh is there I know
one girl that looks good at 300 pounds
there's a reason you remember because
it's rare
I just want to clarify
get some fact then I'll believe you that
fat people are ugly that isn't gonna
help you lose weight
so
focus on yourself focus on myself you
need to focus on yourself you through
yourself at the fat Community yes you
did yeah let's have a community a
community let me in it's a community
no I was 330 pounds
I'm still overweight right now no I'm in
there I don't know what I'm saying is
you teetering right now okay
we get a probationary period I wonder
I wonder if I would have been let it
probably not I don't think people think
when I was okay when I was bigger I
really won wasn't that much bigger and
most people probably wouldn't know how
much I weighed I was actually like in
pretty good shape when I was heavy like
I was doing CrossFit I was just eating
too much
but most people like I don't think would
have known how much I weighed because
everyone's like oh I'm glad you lost all
this weight and had this big
transformation I'm like
I I could show you a picture I really
didn't look that different first of all
who are you to decide
so why would you not bring this up to me
at my like like years ago
Oh I thought you already know I just
didn't know there was a community oh you
Associated already nah let me in man we
were focusing on myself I'm doing great
just if you're wondering also it's
hilarious to me that now you're like if
you're gonna call me ugly that doesn't
make it true you call us ugly if you
call us worthless it doesn't make it
true because you know what I don't think
I called them uglies I said they don't
look good
I'm just if you're gonna quote me
and worthless I never said worthless
I never said where they're putting words
in my mouth and the other thing they
take out of context is they don't know
why I was saying it I wasn't just saying
it to say it the whole point was I bring
girls on my show all the time and we
cannot have an objective conversation
about what looks good and what doesn't
it's like women live in delusion so
what'll happen is I'll give an example
of a fat person I'll be like okay
rank Liza one to ten because the whole
point is women think everyone's a 10
everyone's beautiful and the whole point
of the conversation with some girls are
more beautiful some girls are less
beautiful and I said okay rank lizzo one
to ten and I have had I'm just on my
last like frustration with it because
I've had so many girls come on my show
and say lizzo's a 10. lizzo's a 10 and
I'm just like guys can we live in
reality she's not a 10. so I said come
on and like I don't remember exactly the
name someone who looks good at 300
pounds but it was the whole reason I
said it was because they were trying to
say that fat girls are just as beautiful
as thin girls and there's no beauty
standards and whatever so I was like
guys come on name someone that looks
good at 300 pounds and then the
community's like well there's this one
exception it's like like the more they
argue with me the more they prove my
point that women live in delusions
I'm beautiful but more importantly I'm
beautiful on the inside
what you're putting out from the inside
makes it the same like maybe you're
[ __ ] gross and you're hot maybe you
need some [ __ ] therapy also oh and
then they'll be like you look bad on the
inside I'm like lady you cannot stop it
stop it
why do these women think the biggest
insult and then is that a group why the
[ __ ] you bring us into this [ __ ] man
damn I thought we were gonna be out the
combo for one video and dance he had to
bring men into this too she said it man
he said that's it let's keep keep your
neck keep my name out your [ __ ] mouth
man God can everyone go one video
without blaming men oh it was so close
like okay cool Kyle I don't wanna [ __ ]
you either keep him keep him I'm I'm
good thank you she's okay look look this
now is starting to bother me Marcel you
know why because Kyle had nothing to
talk to her is you bringing us into this
[ __ ] for what
the [ __ ] this fall yo this is crazy
please she said it I've also I also
think she was wrong what the [ __ ] is
Kyle what's her name I think even when
you are obese you should love yourself
though I hate that especially if you
haven't been there that's fine I mean
but you still like want to if you want
if you want to improve especially stay
healthy you do that but yeah I don't
think like it should automatically mean
yeah in yourself because your instinct
is gonna be to hate yourself because
like you're not gonna feel beautiful and
it's probably because you did you did
lose some of that along the way but it's
a horrible feeling because you begin to
like guilt yourself and like it's a
cycle where it's like you feel bad so
you eat and then now like I don't know I
explain it to you man but the best thing
you can do is love yourself so she's
right about that love yourself and uh
doesn't mean that you wouldn't look
better if you got fit please no thank
you
thank you very much to all the body
positive whales coming after me right
now
see
see wait it wants to hate on me for
using the term whales they'll still
laugh when I say it they'll still laugh
like you see this they're they think
it's funny they think it's funny then
they're like ah she probably shouldn't
have but they're like ah
okay
because she she lost a lot of weight too
she lost it yeah she does oh wow I'll be
honest
just pearly things I'm I'm happy you
lost a lot of weight
but you were also me
really yes
yes [ __ ] uh let me keep talking she's
like a four nah yes hold on let her keep
talking
you know what's funny I agree I'm like I
don't that's the funny thing is that's
the first thing they'll say it's like
you're mid I'm like mid is normal
that's not really an insult like you're
average looking I'm like okay most
people are average
um I give myself a five that's a little
lower than I give myself I would prefer
a five I feel like I can I can bargain
with you for a five and honestly
if I'm if I'm a five now or you say four
four now I was probably a negative two
when I was heavier
so [ __ ] I'll take a four I'll take a
four
how the most inclusive people
can mean real quick when you say [ __ ]
that they don't like that's true yeah
that's true that's actually true yeah
but the nice house those [ __ ] is the
worst they're the meanest people how are
you gonna how are you how are you
expecting to act like I get what you're
saying but like come on like you you're
insulting them so of course yes she is
she's not over already she's in she's in
good shape already she can't be she can
be yes yes she can you just hate
insulting it's like
I call you a beautiful Majestic creature
and now I'm the bad guy hey when you and
me that might be true as well that's
what it is but no you can be in you can
be no come on you can be in shape and be
a below a five what the [ __ ] are you
talking about oh y'all are so inclusive
and then like y'all supposed to be happy
and nice but like bro you're insulting
them so like what are you expecting them
to say like well you you thought they're
gonna be like oh you're right you're
right you're right and and also
also I'd like to say the reason the
whale comment started let's let's talk
about where this originated
I think it all started because
there was um I was doing public
interviews and this lady
um I was talking about how and we
weren't even talking about body
positivity I was talking about how women
aren't entitled to security walking home
alone at night like women will always be
like why can't I walk home alone at
night and I'm like okay men can't do it
either like why why are you walking home
alone in a city at night like that's
probably just not safe and this girl got
so mad she hits the mic out of my hand
she's like I'll have you I'll have you
you Evan slag and I'm like and then okay
and maybe I didn't need to do this but I
was like whatever you [ __ ] will
you're a whale that's kind of where it
started so it's kind of like a you know
um I've also never other than that time
attacked anyone personally
um and I also don't think it's an insult
to say you don't deserve a man that
makes six figures and I I'll say the
same thing to the brokies on this app
broke ugly men you probably don't
deserve Victoria's Secret models you
probably don't deserve Beyonce if you
think that's controversial
sue me I don't know you should get in
better shape guys where is the girls
support girls I just said with my whole
chest on air that if you are obese you
don't deserve to be seen respected or
loved
see it's like they put words in my mouth
I never said that
you don't like that she didn't say
respected and call his wills one more
time it is a beautiful reminder that we
are the biggest fish in the sea and you
are nothing yeah yeah beautiful majestic
creatures
and you're only getting attention
because you're hating on us
this little sprinkle of attention that
you've gotten on your social media
career is hating on us because what do
you have other than that they think I
got 60 million views this month from
hating on them do you know
you know delusional you gotta be 60
million views that's more views than
Vlad TV you think I got it all from
talking about yeah okay
narcissists
I do want to say for for us fellow obese
people
um shut up I'm not even joking I'm not
even joking if you make being obese too
big of a personality trait yeah you are
when when you get fit if you get fit
hopefully you get fit for your health
You're Gonna Lose part of yourself yeah
because you no longer and a lot of
people have that like I forgot the word
for is a technical term but it's like
you you think you're still fat you move
and act and feel like you're still fat
but you're not you lost the weight yeah
and so don't like you say us fat like
when you when they talk about it like
it's a community yeah if you got
healthier you would eventually have to
exit that Community you're talking about
like you are I'm [ __ ] I'm still fat see
look at you trying to see him be part of
community no [ __ ] I'm just objectively
you're not you're not you're not with us
anymore man I do not feel I do not feel
bad for women that get rejected because
of their weight I have been overweight
statistically and it was my own damn
fault I hit like 205. I'm six foot you
should not be 205 if you're six foot you
should okay but I did you know [ __ ]
happens I have been overweight
statistically and it was my own damn
fault it was and you can lose it you
can't if your wife gets pregnant and
does not lose the weight and he leaves I
agree I agree with the men I understand
if a girl games 10 20 pounds whatever
like whatever you know your body changes
a little bit but if you're getting 50 75
pounds after a child and some girls do
it without the kid they gave this weight
and they're not even pregnant they get
the ring and they're like let's let
myself go I have a husband he'll stay no
matter what so why why do it to please
him yeah he has a right to leave you he
does does the woman have the same right
I was asked and I said yes the woman I
would say the same thing if a guy gains
a ton away now why why were people
offended by this because people don't
like the truth they don't like being
honest and they don't like giving men
right this is what's crazy okay all the
time we'll say it like a woman can leave
because she's not happy a woman can
leave because she just doesn't feel
herself anymore like Eat Pray loves type
[ __ ] like she left her husband to go to
India and do what a woman can leave
because he's not financially stable he's
like a bum okay yeah I'm not gonna lie
yeah that now they're like oh she's
spitting fast that's a funny thing I'm
like I'm on y'all's team and there I
could see it they're like
okay okay she's kind of submitting uh
let's let's see let's see that's what my
prediction is they're actually gonna end
it
I mean she's she's right
here
instead of like writing down every time
I'm talking to somebody and they say
something I'm like I feel like I'm gonna
forget that in the future let me write
it down I have a [ __ ] notepad with
like the craziest thing that has been
told to me and she said one of them
right there what's that I don't even
feel like myself when I'm around you
like it was long distance like you come
here sometimes how are you not feeling
like yourself well in a positive or
negative way in a negative way I like am
I suffocating you like I'm working most
of the time if anything is the opposite
I need to be spending more time yeah
anyway I just know that's one of the
things like this I heard a lot so you
wrote that down I have a whole Doc it's
[ __ ] crazy this [ __ ] I have my
notepad Okay things that people say when
they're angry and you forget it at the
end of the call right because you kind
of just all mush it into one thought but
then when you individualize it I'm like
yo I can't believe that [ __ ] was said
you know that [ __ ] is crazy as hell
I'm not talking about slight changes to
your body because you had kids I'm
talking about women that let themselves
get obese
oh beasts
and I'm not talking about men that leave
the secondary women's gains always stop
a little bit of weight I'm talking about
men
that tell their wives or feel like they
can't tell their wives okay that they're
gaining weight and they're not sexually
attracted to them anymore that's an
important part of a marriage what's she
saying I agree it is like most women are
gonna be too sensitive for you to even
that's a funny thing I'm like
yeah yeah they start the video and
they're like I disagree and then I talk
more and they're like well she kind of
has a point which is which is also like
she said most men don't some men are not
going to feel comfortable even having it
because they didn't know for a fact how
I was going to be interpreted I agree
with what she's saying you can't even
you know what's funny the last video
they reacted to actually wasn't from
this time around I've been canceled
twice by the fat chicks by the walls
um once was like six months ago and then
the next time it's like it comes in
waves make a comment really you can't
even make a negative comment on your
girl's body it's not possible without
her taking that as like the she thinks
I'm hideous yeah for sure you could be
like your toe looks funny today and
she'd be like nah this [ __ ] hates me
I'm hideous to him it's a long
explanation just to say I was hating on
fat people hey look she's right about
like yeah come on man it's like it's in
your like for me when I'm in a
relationship is the opposite the fat
people feel like they can't be made fun
of I made fun of a lot of I made fun of
women
dudes sometimes it's like
yeah anyways
I just feel like fat chicks like feel
like they're above being made fun of
and I don't subscribe for me I don't
know why I feel like is my duty to like
let me get it together because like
right now in 40 years from now like I
want to be healthy mobile moving and
look good for your future wife bro fat
people can be ugly bro I don't know what
to tell y'all bro and and quite frankly
for most people I'm just gonna cut into
the table let's cut to it man fat people
for majority of people are ugly bro
yeah
so you agree okay that's for
okay really yes I don't know why I said
that
fat people for most people are ugly like
so denying that truth is just I don't
know what to tell you either lose weight
or add value in other capacities that
allow people to overlook your fatness I
don't know that's that's literally it
bro one of the other or accept the fact
that you're fat and you're gonna have a
hard time finding people a harder time
now does that mean that you don't
deserve love I think that's crazy I
think that dessert
ah why are you entitled to love nobody's
entitled to love anyway that that is
where she crossed the line that's just
absurd that was yeah that's right
because deserving love and I also said
they don't deserve a man that makes six
figures but whatever whatever it's like
you don't deserve Beyonce
crazy love should really and truly have
to do with your character and not what
you look like because again you can be
skinny or in shape have the fattest sad
you still have to have sex with that
person but you have to you can be a
great person but if that person doesn't
want to bang you
it probably not gonna fall in love
anyways that's biggest biggest dick be
mad tall whatever right it still doesn't
matter though you saying that I should
be in love I should I deserve love
because I got a fat ass it's crazy
somebody said that I should yeah so it's
equally
equally someone says I deserve love
because I'm
sorry don't Becky Becky Diane
deserve love because I got an 80s is
crazy like I'll be dad just be absurd
like if a [ __ ] said that right so you
deserving love should not have to do
with your your like the shadow status
that we all determine Beauty by it
should be your actual character who you
are as a person yeah that sounds nice
but it's not it's based on how you look
that's where it starts other people have
to be attracted to you and then that
make six figures tend to be attracted to
thin women I don't think I would be
picked by them either like chill out
y'all anyways playback
um sorry this reaction video is just off
of my phone so I wish it was a little
more
you know
intense but I am a fan of you guys so
you know
um I would appreciate I feel like I
should get a five for the one to ten
Rank and I feel like I could get a five
but
um I'm a big fan of the videos
um so thank you for reacting even if
it's you know to disagree with me I
still am a big fan of reaction channels
so
to everyone watching like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible